gas umlage erst beschlossen und jetzt
die mehrwertsteuer auf der anderen seite
auf gas wieder runter erklärt uns gerne
als umlage ist ja so gedacht dass man
die mehrkosten die jetzt den versorgern
entstehen möglichst verteilen will in
die breite auf uns alle daran wie allem
er aber nicht einzelne so extrem viel
dass sie sich das überhaupt nicht mehr
leisten können so zumindest der gedanke
und ist es aber so wenn der preis steigt
dann steigt natürlich auch das geld was
der staat dadurch kassiert über die
steuer deswegen hat die bundesregierung
besonders er habe sich dafür eingesetzt
zu sagen und christian lindner wir
nehmen die mehrwertsteuer wieder raus
und kassieren auf diesen mehrbetrag
keine mehrwertsteuer er sagt aber die eu
das geht so nicht es muss mindestens
fünf prozent steuern erhoben werden herr
scholz hat sich jetzt offensichtlich auf
7 prozent da festgelegt und das ist das
was wir zu haben aber nochmal kann mir
als gaskunde es ist nicht völlig wurscht
sein wie das heißt ob das mehrwertsteuer
heißt oder gas umlage am ende wird zeit
brutal teurer jetzt haben sie es aber
sehr umständlich beschlossen erst diese
gas umlage macht richtig viel teurer und
gehen jetzt sozusagen wieder schrittchen
zurück und senken die mehrwertsteuer
also für gaskunden ist es schwer
verständlich macht warum gehen sie nicht
dann bin ich auf fünf prozent runter was
die eu ja erlaubt hätte sie wollten auf
0% sozusagen sie gehen jetzt auch fünf
shows würde wahrscheinlich damit
argumentieren ja das muss sozial gerecht
jetzt wieder gemacht werden hat ein
weiteres entlastungs paket angekündigt
dass in den kommenden wochen kommen soll
das jetzt gesprochen wird sagt er hat
auch mal seinen satz wiederholt you
never walk alone da kommt eine weitere
entlastung von dem wir noch nicht wissen
wie sie aussieht und da möchte er
möglicherweise auf diese zwei prozent
mehrwertsteuer mehr die jetzt doch kommt
zurück greifen auf dieses geld um die
entlastung damit vielleicht wieder zu
bezahlen erwarten fühlt sich so an als
ob viele deutsche bürger alarmglocken
würde warum diese fünf prozent nicht
wieso diese 7%
geplanten weiteres paket dafür braucht
er wohl geld tatsächlich muss er das
eigentlich jetzt erst mal erklären man
wollte 0 prozent durchsetzen gegen der
eu die eu sagt ihr müsst 5 prozent
mehrwertsteuer erheben wie kommt man
dann auf 7 prozent dem ergebnis dass
bleibt hier zunächst offen da wird sich
doch einige kritische nachfragen
gefallen ist also damit er anschließend
noch ein bisschen entlasten kann
entlastet er jetzt weniger bei der gas
mehrwertsteuer das ist eigentlich auch
eine irre geschichte danke sebastian
geisler unser bild politik reporter hier
bei uns im studio das noch mal zusammen
fast die nachricht dieses tages also
nach der gas umlage wird die
mehrwertsteuer auf gas gesenkt das hat
der kanzler eben angekündigt von 19 auf
7 macht dann das gas also wieder ein
bisschen günstiger als es vorher teurer
geworden ist
[Musik]